Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT BREAKING
$10 MILLION.
YOWZA.
EVERYBODY'S INTRIGUED NOW.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
[ Echoing ]
INTRODUCING MR. MARK CUBAN!
BOO!
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I GIVE YOU $1.5 MILLION...
WHOO-HOO-HOO!
...I START WITH 50%.
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THESE GUYS
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
BIG GUY?
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
GIVE HER A DEAL.
I'M NOT TRYING TO MAKE FRIENDS.
YOU WANT A FRIEND,
BUY A DOG.
OH, MY GOD.
I DON'T CARE.
OH, OKAY.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS AN INNOVATIVE WAY
TO GET THE MOST
OUT OF YOUR WORKOUTS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS PATRICK WHALEY,
AND I'M THE FOUNDER AND C.E.O.
OF TITIN.
I'M HERE SEEKING $500,000 FOR
A 5% EQUITY STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
YOWZA.
TITIN IS A PATENTED,
FORM-FITTING,
WEIGHTED COMPRESSION GEAR
THAT IS DESIGNED AROUND
THE HUMAN ANATOMY.
OUR APPAREL USES GEL WEIGHTS
AS INSERTS
THAT ARE THE SAME DENSITY
AS YOUR OWN MUSCLE TISSUE,
AND YOU CAN ALSO
HEAT IT OR FREEZE IT,
SO IT'S GREAT
FOR HEALING SORE MUSCLES
AND IMPROVING RECOVERY TIMES.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SHOW YOU THAT
THERE IS A BETTER WAY TO TRAIN.
THE ONLY QUESTION LEFT IS...
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
...WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
CAN KEEP UP?
TALK SCIENCE TO ME.
SURE.
WE'VE HAD INCREASE
IN LACTIC-ACID THRESHOLD.
IN MAX VO2 LEVELS.
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD ATHLETES GAIN
2 INCHES ON A MAX VERT AFTER --
I DON'T GIVE A DAMN
ABOUT WHAT THE ATHLETES DO.
YOU'RE NOT TALKING SCIENCE.
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO GIVE ME
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION.
TALK SCIENCE TO ME.
OKAY. THE CONCEPT IS BEING ABLE
TO WEAR A SUIT
THAT IS DESIGNED
AROUND THE HUMAN ANATOMY.
THE GEL'S THE SAME DENSITY
AS YOUR OWN MUSCLE TISSUE,
SO WHEN YOU WEAR IT,
IT BECOMES A PART OF YOU,
WHICH BECOMES AN INTERNAL LOAD
VERSUS AN EXTERNAL LOAD.
IT'S LIKE TRAINING ON EARTH
AND COMPETING ON THE MOON.
SO, YOU'RE TELLING US
WITH A PADDED BRA,
I CAN JUMP 13% HIGHER?
NOW, THE CONCEPT IS
OUR 8 POUNDS
FEELS LIKE A 20-POUND
WEIGHT VEST.
OH, SO YOU'RE SAYING IT'S
JUST LIKE THE OLD ANKLE WEIGHTS
THAT WE USED TO WEAR
WHEN WE WERE KIDS
THAT MAKES YOU FEEL LIGHTER?
EXACTLY, BUT -- RIGHT.
ANKLE WEIGHTS
AND WRIST WEIGHTS --
SO, WAIT. YOU WANT TO GIVE ME
A VALUATION OF --
WHAT IS IT --
Herjavec: $10 MILLION, MARK.
...$10 MILLION
FOR ANKLE WEIGHTS?
John: WAIT, WAIT.
DON'T BEAT THE GUY UP
JUST YET.
YOU GOT TO HAVE VISION.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT IT'S GONNA BE
WORTH NEXT YEAR.
PATRICK, CAN I SEE ONE?
THANK YOU.
Herjavec:
HOW MUCH DOES IT WEIGH?
IT ACTUALLY WEIGHS 8 POUNDS.
WE ALSO HAVE WEIGHTED SHORTS
THAT ARE ABOUT 5 POUNDS.
THEY'RE WEIGHTED WEIGHTS THAT
YOU CAN PUT IN CLOTHING THAT --
THOSE HAVE BEEN AROUND
FOR YEARS, RIGHT?
SO YOU'RE SAYING
THIS IS A LITTLE BETTER DESIGN?
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT
WEARING A WEIGHT VEST
APPLIES ALL THE WEIGHT
ON YOUR SHOULDERS.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER, I WAS ALWAYS
THE SKINNY KID IN SCHOOL. YEAH.
AND I USED TO OVERSTUFF MY BOOK
BAG WITH BOOKS
AND DO SHOULDER SHRUGS ON
THE WAY TO CLASS, TRYING
TO BULK UP MY SHOULDERS.
THE PROBLEM THAT I REALIZE
IS THAT
APPLYING ALL THE WEIGHT
ON YOUR SHOULDERS
ACTUALLY RUINS YOUR POSTURE
AND CAUSES YOU TO SLOUCH.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU MAKING?
SO, LAST MONTH, WE ALMOST BROKE
$1 MILLION IN REVENUE.
WHAT? WOW.
LAST MONTH?
LAST MONTH ALONE, YEAH.
$1 MILLION?
OKAY.
THE SALES ARE IMPRESSIVE.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
ARE YOU A DOCTOR?
I'M A MECHANICAL ENGINEER
FROM GEORGIA TECH.
I SPECIALIZE IN BIOMECHANICS,
AND I ACTUALLY DEVELOPED THIS
WHILE I WAS IN SCHOOL.
AND WHERE ARE YOU SELLING
THIS STUFF?
MAINLY ONLINE RETAILERS.
WE'RE NOW TALKING WITH MULTIPLE
BRICK-AND-MORTAR STORES.
WE JUST SOLD TO THE LARGEST
MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION COMPANY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO, LAST YEAR,
HOW MUCH DID YOU DO?
WE DID ABOUT $600,000
IN REVENUE.
WHAT DID YOU NET
OFF OF THAT?
LAST YEAR
WAS AN INTERESTING STORY.
IN 2012, I ACTUALLY CLOSED A
DEAL WITH A VENTURE CAPITALIST.
THEY DECIDED THAT IT WAS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE COMPANY
FOR US TO ACTUALLY BRING ON
AN EXECUTIVE CHAIR.
WE BURNED THROUGH THE ENTIRE
INVESTMENT WITHIN SIX MONTHS.
HOW MUCH
WAS THE INVESTMENT?
IT WAS ABOUT $1 MILLION.
WHAT -- THIS GUY BLEW THROUGH
THE MONEY. WHAT DID HE DO WRONG?
THERE WERE CHARGES THAT
I WOULDN'T HAVE --
I WOULDN'T HAVE MADE.
THERE WERE DECISIONS THAT
I PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE MADE.
HOWEVER, AS OF LAST WEEK,
I ACTUALLY BOUGHT THEM OUT.
OKAY. WHERE DID YOU GET
THE CAPITAL TO BUY THEM OUT?
ACTUALLY FROM SALES.
WE'RE ABOUT 30% NET PROFIT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DEBT?
WE HAVE NO DEBT.
DO YOU OWN 100%
OF THE EQUITY NOW?
BETWEEN ME AND MY FATHER,
WE OWN 100% OF THE EQUITY.
WHAT WILL THE SALES BE
THIS YEAR, PATRICK?
WE'RE LOOKING AT BREAKING
$10 MILLION THIS YEAR.
WOW.
POSSIBLY $16 MILLION,
DEPENDING ON INVENTORY.
I MEAN, RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE SOLD OUT.
John: YOU'RE GONNA BREAK
$10 MILLION THIS YEAR?
EASILY, YEAH.
EASILY?
SO, WHO'S
YOUR PRIMARY CUSTOMER?
THE MILITARY AND CrossFit.
AND THEY'RE WILLING TO PAY
HOW MUCH FOR A SHIRT?
RIGHT NOW, WE SELL
A THREE-PART SYSTEM FOR $250.
IT COMES AS A COVER SHIRT,
A POCKET SHIRT,
AND A FULL SET OF GEL.
HOW MUCH DO YOU SELL IT
TO THE STORES FOR?
$137 OR SO.
WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT YOU'RE GONNA
HOCKEY-STICK
TO $10 MILLION?
WE HAVE ABOUT $1.4 MILLION
OF PURCHASE ORDERS
THAT I CAN'T FULFILL,
AND THE REASON
IS BECAUSE I'M TAKING
ALL THE PROFIT TO THEN BUY OUT
MY INVESTORS AND TRY TO --
TRY TO GET A CLEAN SLATE.
I'M STRUGGLING WITH YOUR
$10-MILLION VALUATION.
IT'S ALL BASED ON YOU HITTING
A STRATOSPHERIC GROWTH RATE.
WE'VE ALREADY HIT IT.
WE'VE HAD --
WELL, YOU HAVEN'T HIT IT.
YOU HAVEN'T HIT IT.
AND SO I HAVE TO PAY
FOR NEXT YEAR'S SALES
AS IF THEY'VE ALREADY
OCCURRED TODAY.
LOOK, PATRICK, MY B.S. METER
IS GOING THROUGH THE ROOF.
BECAUSE I SAY,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WANT ALL MY GUYS ON THE
MAVERICKS TO JUMP 13% HIGHER."
OKAY, GREAT.
I BRING YOU TO THE MAVERICKS,
SIT WITH MY DOCTOR.
"PATRICK SAYS
HE CAN INCREASE
OUR VERTICAL LEAPS OF ALL OF OUR
PLAYERS BY 13%."
THAT'S THE TRUTH?
YEAH, THE RESEARCH STUDIES
ARE PROVEN.
WE'VE HAD STUDIES
FROM TEXAS TECH,
PENN STATE,
MULTIPLE OTHER UNIVERSITIES.
AND WHAT WAS
THE RESEARCH INTO?
USING WEIGHT
TO INCREASE MAX VERT
OR TO INCREASE YOUR MAX VO2 --
THAT'S NOTHING NEW.
THAT'S LIKE -- THAT'S ANYTHING.
BUT WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS WE'VE MADE IT BETTER.
AGAIN, YOU GAVE ME
AN ANECDOTAL EXAMPLE, RIGHT?
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT. YEAH.
WHY NOT
GET SOMEBODY TO SAY,
"THIS IS WHY
WE'RE A BETTER SOLUTION"?
WE ARE GETTING THAT RESEARCH
FROM MULTIPLE UNIVERSITIES.
SEE, MY [BLEEP] METER'S
GOING NUTS!
RIGHT? BECAUSE
WHY NOT JUST HAVE
ONE UNIVERSITY STUDY IT IN-DEPTH
AND COME BACK WITH AN ANSWER?
BUT WHEN YOU SAY,
"THIS UNIVERSITY, THIS --"
BUT IT'S ALSO
A MARKETING EFFORT, AS WELL.
WE'RE NOW EXPOSING
MORE UNIVERSITIES
AND MORE COLLEGES...
I'M OUT.
Herjavec: PATRICK...
OKAY.
...LET ME TAKE ANOTHER CRACK AT
IT. YOU'RE STRADDLING THE LINE.
MARK HAS REAL ATHLETES,
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES,
PROFESSIONAL DOCTORS.
EITHER YOU'RE IN THAT MARKET,
WITH A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF CREDIBILITY
THAT YOU CAN STAND UP
TO CLAIMS LIKE THAT...
YEAH.
...OR YOU SAY,
"THIS IS PURPOSELY GEARED
TOWARDS THE WEEKEND ATHLETE,"
LIKE ME.
MY CHALLENGE IS,
YOU'RE VERY UNCLEAR.
EVASIVE ANSWERS --
I'M NOT TRYING
TO DO THAT AT ALL.
I MEAN, WE'VE --
WE'VE HAD ALL THE RESEARCH
VALIDATED WITH UNDER ARMOUR.
BUT SEE? OKAY.
YEAH?
EVEN WHEN YOU SAY THAT,
YOU'RE MAKING GENERALIZATIONS.
YOU DON'T POINT
TO SPECIFICS.
YOU MAKE ME UNCOMFORTABLE,
AND IF I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH THE PERSON...
I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY,
I'M NOT A SPORTS GUY.
I LOOK AT IT AS A CONSUMER.
IF I WERE A GUY,
AND I WASN'T BUFF,
I'D WEAR THAT INTO THE GYM,
AND I'D FEEL BETTER
ABOUT MYSELF.
BUT IT'S NOT HITTING ME
AS SOMETHING
THAT I WANT TO INVEST IN,
AND SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY, FORGET
ALL THE RESEARCH STUFF.
WHAT YOU HAVE AND WHAT YOU
SHOULD HAVE FOCUSED ON,
I BELIEVE, IS SALES.
YOU HAVE SALES.
TO ME, IT'S APPAREL --
MAYBE EXTREME APPAREL.
AND IT HAS THE MERITS AND THE
RISKS OF THE APPAREL INDUSTRY.
SO I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $500,000
FOR 15%.
VALUE'S AT AROUND
$3.3 MILLION.
I THINK IT'S INTRIGUING
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE, YOU KNOW?
AND YOUR STYLE IS --
YOU KIND OF FIT INTO
THE ARROGANT ASS FACTOR.
[ CUBAN LAUGHS ]
I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
I'M NOT TRYING
TO MAKE FRIENDS.
YOU WANT A FRIEND,
BUY A DOG.
I'M TRYING TO MAKE MONEY,
OKAY?
I CAN BE YOUR INVESTOR.
MAYBE WE WILL
BE FRIENDS.
WHO KNOWS? BUT YOU ARE
A BIT OF A [BLEEP]
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, MY GOD.
I DON'T CARE. LOOK.
YOU NEED HONEST PARTNERS.
I'M ONE OF THOSE.
ALL RIGHT?
OH, MY GOD.
Whaley: WELL, I MEAN...
I'M SINCERELY SORRY THAT YOU
FEEL THAT WAY ABOUT ME.
DON'T FEEL SORRY!
BUT THERE IS AN OFFER THERE --
$500,000 FOR 15%.
UM...
I DON'T HEAR
ANY OTHER OFFERS.
I'M GONNA PUT
AN OFFER ON THE TABLE.
FIRST OF ALL,
I'M HAVING THE SAME CHALLENGE
THAT THE OTHER SHARKS
ARE HAVING.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I SHOULD TRUST YOU OR NOT.
WELL, I AM AN EAGLE SCOUT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT HELPS.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
BEFORE I MAKE THE OFFER,
WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO UTILIZE
THE MONEY FOR?
INVENTORY. WE ARE COMPLETELY
SOLD OUT. WE GET INVENTORY IN,
AND IN 24 HOURS, IT'S GONE.
OKAY,
THAT'S A GOOD PROBLEM.
SO I'M -- I'M WILLING
TO GIVE YOU THE 500K FOR 20%.
THAT'S HIGHER
THAN KEVIN'S.
YES, BECAUSE I'M WILLING
TO HANDLE THE INVENTORY
AND HANDLE THE PRODUCTION.
HMM.
ALL RIGHT, PATRICK,
YOU'VE GOT TWO OFFERS.
TIME TO MAKE A DECISION.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
PATRICK HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE --
$500,000 FOR A 15% STAKE
FROM KEVIN,
AND $500,000 FOR A 20% STAKE
FROM DAYMOND.
UM...
John: YOU CAN COUNTER.
YOU REALLY WOULD SELL
THESE THINGS TO PEOPLE?
SOME GUY'S GONNA JUST PUT THIS
THING ON, TRY TO DO TOO MUCH,
DROP DEAD OF A HEART ATTACK.
YOU HAVE THAT
IN ANY WEIGHT TRAINING.
YEAH, BUT, NO. BUT HE'S MAKING
CLAIMS, AND HE'S TRYING --
HE'S TRYING TO LIVE UP
TO THE CLAIMS.
PATRICK,
DON'T LET THE FLOOR
GET AWAY FROM YOU.
YOU'VE GOT
TWO OFFERS HERE.
MARK STARTED TO TALK.
DON'T LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY.
EITHER COUNTER
OR TAKE THE DEAL.
I'M FINE
WITH A $5-MILLION VALUATION
IF WE CAN TRY TO GET THERE.
IF WE CAN GET THERE,
WE CAN MAKE THIS THING
A STRATOSPHERIC SUCCESS.
WE'RE ALREADY GROWING --
PATRICK, STOP SELLING.
I MEAN, DAYMOND, LOOK.
YOU'RE IN THE APPAREL INDUSTRY.
YOU'VE BEEN THERE.
YOU'VE HAD PEOPLE TELL YOU
IT COULDN'T BE DONE.
I NEED YOU
TO BELIEVE IN ME.
I KNOW
I CAN GET THIS DONE.
I'D LOVE
TO HAVE YOU ON BOARD.
YOU'D LOVE TO HAVE ME ON BOARD
FOR HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
WELL --
MY $500,000 IS MY BUY-IN
TO HELP YOU PRODUCE AND
MANUFACTURE AND RUN EVERYTHING.
I THINK HE SAID NO, DAYMOND.
HE MADE YOU A COUNTER.
I DON'T WANT
TO SAY NO TO ANYBODY. I'M --
10%? IT'S NOT ENOUGH EQUITY.
IT'S TOO SMALL.
I'M GONNA STICK AT 15%.
IT'S REASONABLE.
IT'S A $3.3-MILL
VALUATION.
WOULD YOU MIND DOING IT
AT $750,000 FOR 15%?
NO.
$500,000 IS A LOT OF CASH.
ALL RIGHT, SO, I'M GONNA HAVE TO
STICK TO 20%.
PATRICK,
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
[ SIGHS ]
UM...
DAYMOND...
...I'D LOVE TO TAKE YOUR OFFER.
OH.
ALL RIGHT.
WOW.
NICE.
GOOD DEAL.
I THOUGHT MAYBE YOU WERE
COMING HERE NOT TO MAKE A DEAL.
NO, I WANTED TO MAKE A DEAL.
ACTUALLY, I PICKED YOU.
I WANTED TO DO A DEAL.
WHY WERE YOU BEING
SO DIFFICULT?
I WASN'T TRYING TO BE DIFFICULT.
I MEAN, WE HAVE --
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROOF
AND VALIDATION.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY
SCREWED YOU OVER THE FIRST TIME.
YEAH. YEAH.
RIGHT? I GOT YOU.
I WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO
VALIDATE THIS STUFF,
ALL RIGHT?
IT'S ALL VALIDATED.
AND WE'RE GONNA
PROVE THESE GUYS WRONG.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
KEVIN,
YOU ARE MR. WONDERFUL.
I KNOW THAT WITH CERTAINTY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, ALL.
THE HARDEST PART
ABOUT GOING INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS YOU HAVE A SPLIT SECOND
TO MAKE A DECISION.
[ EXHALES SHARPLY ]
[ CHUCKLES ]
IT WAS EXTREMELY FEROCIOUS,
AND, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
I MADE A DEAL WITH DAYMOND,
AND IT WAS PROBABLY
THE BEST DEAL I'VE EVER DONE.
SO, YOU FELT COMFORTABLE
PARTNERING WITH HIM.
DOES HE HAVE $1 MILLION IN SALES
OR NOT?
HE WAS ROMANCING THE TRUTH.
LISTEN, MAYBE HE'S A JERK,
BUT NOW HE'S MY JERK.
Narrator: IN SEASON 5, WE
WATCHED MELISSA AND RICK HINNANT
MAKE A DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN
FOR THEIR FASHION SOCK COMPANY,
GRACE AND LACE.
WE CAME IN WITH A STRATEGY,
AND WE KNEW WHO WE WANTED.
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
WE ALWAYS KNEW THAT BARBARA
WOULD MAKE
THE PERFECT PARTNER FOR US.
Melissa: NOT ONLY HAS SHE
GIVEN US INCREDIBLE ADVICE,
SHE HAS OPENED UP INCREDIBLE
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES FOR US.
JOANNA?
BARBARA CORCORAN.
HOW VERY NICE TO MEET YOU.
I BROUGHT MELISSA AND RICK
TO MEET JOANNA COLES,
THE EDITOR-IN-CHIEF
OF COSMOPOLITAN MAGAZINE.
WE'VE GOT A FEW SAMPLES
WE BROUGHT FOR YOU TODAY.
Corcoran: COSMOPOLITAN HAS
17 MILLION READERS A MONTH.
WE WANT TO BE
IN THE PAGES OF COSMOPOLITAN.
THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
WE'VE DECIDED
TO FEATURE GRACE AND LACE
IN OUR FEBRUARY ISSUE.
Melissa: THIS IS HUGE.
I MEAN, THE CHANCE
FOR OUR BRAND TO BE
IN A MAJOR MAGAZINE LIKE THIS
BLOWS MY MIND.
A YEAR BEFORE
"SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD DONE A LITTLE OVER
$1 MILLION IN SALES.
NOT EVEN A YEAR LATER, WE HAVE
OVER $6.5 MILLION IN SALES.
WE ARE ECSTATIC ABOUT
WHAT BARBARA HAS DONE FOR US
AND THE REACH
THAT THIS COULD PROVIDE.
THESE ARE FABULOUS.
[ MAN SPEAKS HINDI ]
[ CROWD CHEERING ]
Melissa: THE GREATEST THING
ABOUT OUR SUCCESS
IS THAT IT HAS POSITIONED US
TO GIVE BACK.
WE RECENTLY WENT TO INDIA
TO OPEN TWO GRACE AND LACE
ORPHANAGES.
WE WERE ABLE
TO TAKE 100 KIDS OFF THE STREETS
AND GIVE THEM FOOD, A BED.
IT'S A CAUSE
THAT MEANS SO MUCH TO US.
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD.
WE CHASED OUR DREAMS, AND NOW
WE'RE SEEING THEM COME TRUE.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL FEELING.
I'M ERIC BANDHOLZ,
AND I'M A BEARDSMAN
FROM SPOKANE, WASHINGTON.
I TOTALLY LIVE THE BEARDED
LIFESTYLE ALL THE TIME,
AND IT TAKES A LOT OF WORK TO
TAKE CARE OF A BEAUTY LIKE THIS.
THE BEST PART OF HAVING
A BEARD THIS AWESOME --
BEING ABLE TO SHOW IT OFF.
THE BEST PLACE FOR THAT
IS A BEARD AND MOUSTACHE
COMPETITION.
[ INDISTINCT CONVERSATIONS ]
ARE YOU GUYS FROM HERE?
I DIDN'T ALWAYS HAVE THIS
BEAUTIFUL FACE MANE RIGHT HERE.
I USED TO WORK AS A FINANCIAL
ADVISOR AT A BIG BANK.
THEIR POLICY WAS NO FACIAL HAIR.
I LEFT MY JOB 'CAUSE I'M A
BEARDSMAN, AND IT'S IN MY BLOOD,
AND THAT'S WHEN I HAD
A GLORIOUS IDEA.
THERE'S ALL TYPES
OF BEARDSMEN OUT THERE.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN ONE BRAND
TO UNITE THEM...UNTIL NOW.
I'VE BEEN GROWING OUR BUSINESS
ORGANICALLY THROUGH OUR PROFITS,
BUT I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO PAY MYSELF A DIME.
SO MUCH OF BEING A MAN
IS PROVIDING FOR YOUR FAMILY,
AND IT'S ALWAYS GONNA BE
A CHIP ON MY SHOULDER
UNTIL I CAN BRING IN
THE SUPPORT MY FAMILY NEEDS.
WITH THE SHARKS' INVESTMENT,
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
All: BEARDSMEN!
WHAT'S GOING ON, SHARKS?
IT IS YOUR BOY, ERIC BANDHOLZ,
WITH BEARDBRAND...
[ CHUCKLES ]
...COMING TO YOU TODAY
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PURCHASE 15% OF OUR BUSINESS
FOR $400,000.
NOW, DAYMOND, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU WERE DOING IN 2012,
BUT I, MYSELF,
WAS AT A BEARD COMPETITION,
AND I LEARNED
A VERY IMPORTANT THING.
SEE, BACK THEN,
BEARDSMEN WERE THOUGHT OF
AS LUMBERJACKS OR HIPPIES.
AND WHAT I NOTICED
WAS A NEW TYPE OF BEARDSMAN,
SOMETHING WE COINED
THE URBAN BEARDSMAN.
NOW, THESE WERE MEN
WHO WERE PASSIONATE
NOT ONLY
ABOUT THEIR FACIAL HAIR,
BUT ALSO THEIR STYLE,
THEIR CAREERS,
AND THEIR INDEPENDENCE.
SO WE UNITED THE COMMUNITY
AND STARTED OFFERING THEM
SOME REALLY AWESOME PRODUCTS.
BEARD OIL
WILL SOFTEN UP YOUR BEARD,
HELP ELIMINATE BEARD FLAKES,
AND...
[ SNIFFS ]
WHOO-HOO-HOO!
IT SMELLS FANTASTIC.
ALL YOU GOT TO DO IS DROP
A COUPLE DROPS IN YOUR HAND...
RUB IT INTO THE BEARD...
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ Quietly ] NO.
NOW, WE ARE IN THE RENAISSANCE
OF A FACIAL-HAIR REVOLUTION.
AND BEARDBRAND
IS LEADING THE CHARGE.
WE SEE A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
IN THE MARKETPLACE,
AND WITH YOUR PARTNERSHIP,
WE WILL CHANGE
THE WAY SOCIETY VIEWS BEARDSMEN.
SO, ERIC,
CAN WE SEE THE PRODUCT?
YEAH, YOU CAN, ROBERT.
THANK YOU.
I CAN SMELL IT
OVER HERE.
OH, IT'S A BEARD KIT.
Greiner: SO, TRIMMERS.
SCISSORS.
John: THANK YOU.
COMB.
[ SNIFFS ]
WHOA.
THIS STUFF SMELLS GREAT.
IS THIS KIT FOR GUYS
WITH, LIKE, SERIOUS BEARDS?
Bandholz:
SO, THIS IS, LIKE, THE ULTIMATE
KIT ON THE FACE OF THE PLANET,
ALL RIGHT?
WE SPARED NO EXPENSE THERE.
WE GOT FINE,
BLACK-WALNUT CORNERS.
WE'VE GOT
INCREDIBLE PRODUCTS.
OKAY, SO,
DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
DO WE HAVE SALES?
ABSOLUTELY.
SO, WHAT I NEED TO HEAR
IS YOU'VE GOT SOME REVENUE
BEFORE I ABSOLUTELY
GO TO TOWN ON YOU.
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $2.6 MILLION
FOR YOUR BEARDBRAND
BOX OF STUFF.
YEAH, I THINK MY VALUATION
IS ACTUALLY A PRETTY GOOD DEAL.
WELL, TELL ME MORE.
SO, WE ACTUALLY LAUNCHED
THIS BUSINESS 17 MONTHS AGO.
SO, THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS,
WE DID $9,000 IN SALES.
THE SECOND SIX MONTHS,
WE DID $188,000.
BETTER.
AND THE MOST RECENT,
WE DID OVER $600,000.
WOW.
SO, ALL TOTAL,
WE'VE DONE OVER $800,000.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SAY,
IT SURPRISES ME
BECAUSE I KNOW
IT'S BACK IN STYLE.
BUT THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS
THAT GO THROUGH MY MIND
AS A FEMALE
ABOUT A BEARD LIKE THAT.
LIKE WHAT?
LIKE WHAT, LORI?
LORI,
EVERYBODY'S INTRIGUED NOW.
CAN I TOUCH IT?
YEAH, COME ON UP!
SCRATCH THAT PUPPY,
LORI.
LORI, YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
TOUCH THE PEOPLE.
Greiner:
OH, MY GOD. [ LAUGHS ]
[ Chuckling ]
IT'S A LITTLE --
IT'S A LITTLE LIKE...
LORI, WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
COME ON UP.
YOU CAN ALL TOUCH IT.
I'M NOT TOUCHING
NO OTHER MAN'S BEARD!
WHAT THE HELL'S
WRONG WITH YOU?
DAYMOND, ARE YOU NOT COMFORTABLE
TOUCHING ANOTHER MAN'S BEARD?
NO! I'M NOT TOUCHING
NO WOMAN'S BEARD, EITHER,
SO DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT!
LORI, SIT DOWN!
Bandholz: THE REASON I HAVE A
BEARD IS BECAUSE, DOWN THE LINE,
MY MOM, MY GRANDMA -- THEY ALL
DIG THE DUDE WITH THE BEARD.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO CHICKS DIG BEARDS. THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. WHAT --
LIKE, THINK ABOUT IT.
OF ALL THE ANIMALS OUT THERE,
HUMANS ARE ONE OF THE FEW BREEDS
THAT ACTUALLY GROW FACIAL HAIR.
IT'S A SIGN OF LOVE AND PASSION
THAT WOMEN ARE ATTRACTED TO.
HMM.
Greiner:
IS THERE SOMETHING IN THAT OIL
THAT WILL, LIKE, KEEP FOOD
FROM GETTING STUCK IN IT?
John: SO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA HANG OUT WITH HIM,
AND A CHICKEN WING'S GONNA
DROP OUT OF HIS BEARD?
OUR COMPANY
DOESN'T SELL $800,000
BY SELLING TO JUST GUYS
WITH GIANT BEARDS.
WE CATER
TO ALL BEARDS OF ALL LENGTHS.
ERIC, ARE YOU SELLING THIS
ONLINE? IS THIS IN RETAIL?
SO, WE LAUNCHED
WITH AN ONLINE STORE.
O'Leary:
WHAT WILL SALES BE THIS CALENDAR
YEAR? I HAD A LOT OF HAIR ONCE.
THEN I RAN INTO DEALS LIKE THIS,
AND LOOK WHAT HAPPENED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OKAY, SO LET'S GO. LET'S GO.
WHAT'S THE CALENDAR YEAR?
IT'D BE $1.2 MILLION,
AT LEAST.
AND HOW MUCH WOULD YOU MAKE?
OUR NET PROFIT IS 25%.
BUT YOU'RE PUTTING A VALUE ON
YOUR BUSINESS OF $2.6 MILLION.
ERIC, YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
HIGH-QUALITY STUFF IN HERE.
WHAT'S IT COST YOU TO MAKE?
THAT'S ABOUT $170,
AND THAT'LL COST US
ABOUT 60 OR 70 BUCKS.
HOW LOW
CAN YOU GET YOUR COST?
OUR BEARD OIL
IS THE MAJORITY OF OUR SALES.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF BUSINESS
IS THE OIL?
PROBABLY ABOUT 60%.
WOW.
WOW. AND WHAT'S YOUR MARGIN
ON THE OIL?
SO, WE RETAIL THESE
ANYWHERE FROM $20 TO $30,
AND THEN OUR MARGIN
IS BETWEEN 85% AND 90%.
WHY YOU DOING
ALL THIS OTHER MISHEGOSS
WHEN YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING
THAT'S 80% MARGIN,
THAT IF YOU
KEEP YOUR BEARD,
YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP ON
REPLENISHING IT AND BUYING MORE?
YEAH.
YOU KNOW, IT'D TAKE NOTHING TO
STORE AND SHIP ALL THAT STUFF.
THE BIG THING FOR US
IS BUILDING A BRAND
AND BEING MORE
THAN JUST A PRODUCT COMPANY.
BUT -- BUT YOU'RE
MISSING THE POINT, RIGHT?
YOU'RE --
YOU'RE GOING HIGH END,
AND IT'S GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO SCALE.
YOU MIGHT GET
THE $5 MILLION IN SALES,
BUT AT THAT POINT
IN TIME,
IT'S HARD FOR US
TO GET OUR MONEY BACK.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OUT ALREADY.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, FOR ME,
I'M NOT A BEARD GUY.
I JUST DON'T SEE IT.
I'M OUT.
FOR A COMPANY TO GO
FROM ZERO TO OVER $100,000
PER MONTH IN SALES,
I'M SURE YOU GUYS
DON'T SEE A LOT OF THAT.
LOOK, YOU'RE DOING WELL,
BUT WHAT'S THE MARKET FOR THIS?
NOT FOR WOMEN, NOT FOR KIDS,
NOT FOR MEN WITHOUT BEARDS.
SO THE ONLY THING THAT CAME
INTO MY MIND WAS THE AMISH,
AND THEY DON'T HAVE TVs,
SO I'M OUT.
SO, HOW DO I GET
MY $400,000 BACK?
THAT'S A LOT OF DOUGH,
MY FRIEND.
YOUR BUSINESS IS WORTH
ABOUT $500,000 TO $600,000.
YOU'VE PRICED IT AT A CRAZY
VALUATION OF $2.6 MILLION.
I WOULD HAVE TO OWN
PRETTY WELL THE WHOLE THING,
AND THEN YOU'D BECOME
MY BEARD SLAVE. THAT'D BE IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M OUT.
SO THAT LEAVES
THE FINAL BEARDSMAN,
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL MAN
IN THE ROOM.
Greiner: OOH.
WHERE?
I LIKE THIS GUY.
THIS GUY GETS THIS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
BIG GUY?
I-I FELL IN LOVE WITH YOU.
YOU ARE THE BEARD WHISTLER.
YOU LIVE THIS LIFE.
I THINK YOU GO AND DO $2
MILLION, $3 MILLION, $4 MILLION.
I LOVE INVESTING IN PEOPLE.
SO I GOT CAUGHT UP.
I WAS ACTUALLY
GONNA GIVE YOU AN OFFER,
BUT THEN I HAD TO GO BACK
TO THE VALUATION.
I WOULDN'T GET
MY MONEY BACK
UNTIL MY BEARD WAS LONG
LIKE MOSES, RIGHT? SO...
I'M OUT.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK.
GOOD LUCK, MAN.
GOOD LUCK.
TAKE IT EASY.
AS A WOMAN,
I CAN'T STAND BEARDS LIKE THAT.
I REALLY CAN'T.
YOU WERE DYING TO GO UP THERE
AND TOUCH HIS BEARD.
LORI,
I THINK YOU LIKED HIM.
John: YEAH.
I-I FELT THIS --
YOU WERE DOING
TOO MUCH GIGGLING.
YOU WERE LIKE
A LITTLE SCHOOLGIRL. "OOH!"
LOOK AT HER BLUSHING NOW.
OH, YEAH.
NO, NO, NO.
SHE WAS ALL OVER
THAT BEARD.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WITH THE NEXT GENERATION
OF KARAOKE MACHINES.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ERIC BERKOWITZ,
AND THE GUY
NEXT TO ME...
MY NAME
IS JOHN DEVECKA.
AND TOGETHER
WE'RE COFOUNDERS
OF THE COMPANY SINGTRIX
FROM NEW YORK, NEW YORK.
WE'RE SEEKING $1.5 MILLION IN
EXCHANGE FOR 5% OF OUR COMPANY.
OOH.
WOW.
YOU'VE GOT SOME SALES,
I HOPE.
SINGTRIX IS THE MOST EXCITING
AND REVOLUTIONARY
SINGING EXPERIENCE
THAT'S EVER BEEN CREATED.
NOW EVERYBODY CAN SOUND LIKE
THEIR FAVORITE ROCK STARS
WITH NO EXPERIENCE
NECESSARY.
Berkowitz: IN ORDER TO PROVE
THE POWER OF SINGTRIX,
WE HAD TO FIND
A REALLY AWFUL SINGER.
SO MY PARTNER JOHN
IS GONNA BE SINGING FOR US.
[ Off-key ]
♪ LA ♪
♪ LA-LA-LA ♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ High-pitched, off-key ]
♪ LA-LA-LA ♪
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
ENOUGH.
THIS TIME, HE'S GONNA SING IT
THROUGH THE SINGTRIX UNIT.
IT'S GOING TO HELP HIM SING
IN TUNE,
IT'S GOING TO
PITCH-CORRECT HIM,
AND IT'S GONNA ADD
LIVE VOCAL HARMONIES.
[ UP-TEMPO MUSIC PLAYS ]
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET YOU GUYS GOING.
LET'S GET SOME ENERGY.
NO CLAPPING?
IT'S JUST ME?
GO AHEAD.
WE'RE -- WE'RE
CONCENTRATING.
THERE WE GO.
[ In tune ]
♪ LA, LA-LA-LA ♪
RIGHT HERE.
WOW.
Cuban: OH, MY --
WOW!
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S CRAZY.
GO HIGH.
[ High-pitched, in tune ]
♪ LA-LA-LA ♪
AMAZING.
NICE. NICE.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
FOR YOU GUYS RIGHT NOW
IS WE'RE GONNA CYCLE THROUGH
SOME OF THE EFFECTS
THAT ARE IN
THE UNIT ITSELF.
[ Echoing ]
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN...
INTRODUCING,
FROM THE DALLAS MAVERICKS,
MR. MARK CUBAN!
BOO!
[ Auto-tuned ]
♪ FOR US, BY US, IT'S FUBU ♪
YOU GUYS ARE GOOD AND TERRIBLE.
THEY'RE GOOD AND TERRIBLE.
♪ FUBU ♪
[ Robotic voice ]
WARNING. WARNING.
BAD DEAL ALERT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
MONEY, MONEY,
MONEY, MONEY, MONEY.
YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
[ Very deep voice ]
OH, HI, LORI.
YOU GOT
A BEAUTIFUL SMILE.
LET'S GET TOGETHER
AFTER THE SHOW.
I'LL SEE YOU OUTSIDE
LATER.
[ Normal voice ]
YOU LIKE TO PLAY GUITAR, RIGHT?
[ VOICE IMITATING
ELECTRIC GUITAR ]
[ High-pitched voice ]
CUT THE MUSIC.
I THINK WE'RE DONE HERE
WITH THIS DEMONSTRATION.
WOW.
NICE.
AMAZING.
Berkowitz: SO, THE UNIT HAS
OVER 350 DIFFERENT EFFECTS.
YOU CAN NOW HAVE
A MAN SING LIKE A WOMAN.
YOU COULD HAVE A WOMAN
SING LIKE A MAN.
YOU COULD SING
IN YOUR FAVORITE BARITONE VOICE.
IT'LL WORK
WITH ANY TYPE OF MUSIC.
SO, HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
BACK IN THE '90s,
WE HAD A DRUMMING KARAOKE GAME
CALLED DRUMSCAPE.
I BUILT THE DRUMSCAPE IN
MY PARENTS' GARAGE WHEN I WAS 26
AND FILED ALL THE PATENTS,
WHICH TURNED OUT TO BE
RELATED TO GUITAR HERO,
THE EARLIEST PATENTS.
FAST-FORWARD, WE WIND UP SELLING
OUR PATENTS TO ACTIVISION.
DID YOU DO WELL?
WE DID VERY WELL.
HOW MUCH IS THIS GONNA COST
THE AVERAGE CONSUMER?
RIGHT NOW, THE BUNDLE --
THE 40-WATT SPEAKER,
THE STAND, THE STUDIO,
AND THE MICROPHONE --
IS $345 AT RETAIL.
WE JUST CAME OUT SIX MONTHS AGO,
SO THIS WAS OUR PRIMARY SKU.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS?
$1.2 MILLION.
HOW MANY UNITS IS THAT?
Greiner:
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS?
WAIT, I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE CLEAR ON THIS.
4,000 UNITS.
Berkowitz: 4,000 UNITS.
ALL RIGHT. DOLLARS THAT IT COSTS
YOU TO MAKE THIS BUNDLE.
DOLLARS YOU SELL IT OUT TO
A WHOLESALER OR DISTRIBUTOR FOR.
$150 IS OUR LANDED COST.
WHOLESALE WOULD BE LIKE $265.
TELL ME WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
FROM HERE ON IN.
YOU'RE SAYING THE COMPANY'S
WORTH $30 MILLION.
IT'S NOT BASED
ON THE HISTORICAL SALES.
HERE'S -- HERE'S WHERE WE ARE.
WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
CONSUMER ELECTRONICS COMPANY
WHO WANTS TO TAKE OVER
OUR DISTRIBUTION
IN THE U.S. AND IN EUROPE.
SO, WE'RE EXPECTING TO SELL
30,000 UNITS THIS YEAR.
IS THIS AN EXCLUSIVE
THAT THEY HAVE?
IT WOULD BE AN EXCLUSIVE.
HERE'S WHERE IT'S EASY. IF WE
SELL 30,000 UNITS THIS YEAR,
WHICH IS NOT A LOT
DURING THE HOLIDAY SEASON,
TIMES $250 TO $300,
YOU'RE AT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
$6 MILLION TO $8 MILLION
AT A 40% MARGIN.
YEAH, BUT YOUR COST
IS GONNA RAMP UP, GUYS.
AS YOU GET TO THAT
$6 TO $8 MILLION,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO BUILD
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT GETS MESSY. SO, WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA USE THE MONEY FOR?
WELL, IF WE GO WITH
THIS DISTRIBUTION DEAL,
THAT MONEY'S GONNA BE USED
FOR MAKING NEW PRODUCTS.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
SOMEBODY WRITING A CHECK.
WE'VE HAD LOTS OF PEOPLE
OFFERING US MONEY
AT THE VALUATION THAT WE'VE
PUT OUT THERE, BUT FOR US --
AT $30 MILLION?
$30 MILLION?
AT $30 MILLION.
REALLY?
YES. WE'RE NOT
LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY
TO JUST WRITE US A CHECK,
SAY, "HERE'S THE MONEY, GO."
WE WANT TO GET INVOLVED
WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE GONNA
MAKE US BETTER.
Cuban: HERE'S WHAT I HEAR.
THERE'S A REASON
WHY YOU'RE LOOKING
TO DO A LICENSING DEAL
WITH THIS COMPANY.
THAT'S BECAUSE
IT'S GONNA TAKE
A BOATLOAD OF CASH
TO GET YOU WHERE YOU NEED TO GO.
$1.5 MILLION ISN'T GOING TO DO
IT BECAUSE IT'S HEAVY INVENTORY.
THEN, ON TOP OF THAT,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO SPEND
A BOATLOAD ON MARKETING
AND ADVERTISING, WHICH IS
ONE OF THE REASONS YOU'RE HERE.
FROM WHERE I SIT,
I DON'T SEE IT WORKING.
I'LL BE A CUSTOMER,
BUT I WON'T BE AN INVESTOR.
SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
AND WE RESPECT THAT.
O'Leary:
LET ME THROW OUT AN OFFER HERE.
HERE'S HOW IT'S GONNA WORK.
I GIVE YOU $1.5 MILLION.
I START WITH 50%.
IF YOU GIVE ME BACK MY MILLION
AND A HALF WITHIN 18 MONTHS,
MY EQUITY DROPS DOWN TO 10%.
AT THE END OF IT,
IF YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL,
AND YOU DO THESE DEALS AS YOU
SUGGEST -- 30,000 UNITS --
WE'RE LEFT WITH TWO THINGS.
I HAVE 10% AND A $2.50 ROYALTY
ON THIS DEVICE IN PERPETUITY.
BANG.
THERE IT IS.
LISTEN, I THINK
THAT'S A VERY FAIR OFFER,
BECAUSE EITHER YOU BELIEVE
IN YOUR FUTURE, OR YOU DON'T.
KEVIN, DOES THE ROYALTY
KICK IN
ONLY AFTER
YOU GET YOUR MONEY BACK?
John: AFTER?
YES. IF YOU GUYS HAVE
A BETTER OFFER, LET'S HEAR IT.
Herjavec: I'M GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL MAKE IT
VERY SIMPLE AND VERY CLEAN.
I SEE THIS
AS A LONG-TERM PLAY.
I'LL GIVE YOU
$1.5 MILLION FOR 20%.
WOW, THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
[ WHISTLES ]
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
THANK YOU.
Greiner:
WELL, YOU GUYS ARE IMPRESSIVE,
AND I'D LIKE
TO BE INVOLVED HERE.
I LIKE
WHAT KEVIN OFFERED YOU.
WHAT?
I WOULD GO
$1.5 MILLION AT 30%.
YOU PAY ME BACK MY MONEY,
AND I'LL GO DOWN TO 15%.
AND THEN I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE $2.50
THEREAFTER IN PERPETUITY
PER UNIT SOLD.
John:
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU, LORI?
DID KEVIN BITE YOU
IN THE NECK LAST NIGHT?
I JUST LIKE KEVIN'S OFFER.
LIGHTNING STRUCK ME.
I THINK THIS STRUCTURE
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
I'D JOIN HER ON THAT DEAL.
WHAT'S REASONABLE FOR YOU
IN TERMS OF
HOW FAST YOU CAN PAY US BACK?
THAT WOULD BE
IF WE ACCEPTED THE OFFER.
YEAH. I MEAN, THE -- THE --
THE QUESTION IS --
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT IS
THE OFFER WORTH MONETARILY
THAT WE COULDN'T GET
OUTSIDE OF THIS TANK?
I'LL TELL YOU THE ANSWER.
"SHARK TANK," TWO SHARKS.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
Herjavec: WHEN YOU'RE GROWING
THIS QUICKLY,
THAT IS THE WORST TIME THAT YOU
WANT TO BE PAYING SOMEBODY BACK.
ROBERT'S DONE IT IN A WAY WHERE
IT COSTS YOU A LOT MORE EQUITY.
NO, I'VE DONE IT
OVER THE LONG-TERM.
NO, YOU'VE
COST THEM A FORTUNE.
I'VE DONE IT
OVER THE LONG-TERM.
WELL, WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW
IS --
John: WAIT A MINUTE.
I THINK I CAN HELP YOU
IN SOME AREAS.
I REPRESENT ULTRA MUSIC
FOR LICENSING,
AS WELL AS A LOT OF ARTISTS.
I'M UNDERWRITTEN BY SAMSUNG,
SO I CAN MAKE THE EQUIPMENT.
MY OFFER IS $1.5 MILLION
FOR 25%,
BUT I WILL FINANCE
ALL YOUR ORDERS GOING FORWARD.
THAT MEANS YOU WILL NOT NEED
ANY CAPITAL FOR ORDERS.
IF YOU COVET YOUR EQUITY,
WHICH I BELIEVE YOU DO,
YOU'LL LOOK AT OUR OFFER.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
WELL, WE'RE WILLING
TO INCREASE OUR PERCENTAGE.
SO WE'LL OFFER $1.5 MILLION
FOR 7% IN THE COMPANY.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
John:
$1.5 MILLION FOR 7%?
YOU -- YOU CAME UP
A WHOLE 2%?
IN THIS WORLD, WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH START-UPS,
WELL, I'M SORRY, GUYS.
NO, NO, NO.
IN THIS WORLD,
WE DEAL WITH REALITY.
Herjavec:
JOHN, I GOT TO TELL YOU --
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT PLANET YOU'RE ON,
BUT WE'RE HERE ON EARTH
IN THE SHARK TANK.
BUT HEAR THIS.
WE'VE DONE THIS BEFORE.
WE MADE GUITAR HERO.
THAT WAS THE BIGGEST GAME EVER.
Cuban: YEAH, YOU MADE
GUITAR HERO. YOU DIDN'T SELL
GUITAR HERO, THOUGH.
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
YEAH, THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
I'M OUT.
GUYS, I'M OUT.
Herjavec:
WE'RE SO FAR APART.
I'M OUT.
YOU ARE THE CLASSIC
"YOU'RE DEAD TO ME."
YOU GOT TO GO. I'M OUT.
SO, TURN AROUND, PLEASE.
Berkowitz: THE QUESTION IS,
WAS IT A MATTER OF EGO,
OR WAS IT A MATTER
OF DOLLAR AND CENTS?
MR. WONDERFUL
IS ALWAYS SAYING,
"I'M HERE FOR THE MONEY,
FOR THE MONEY, FOR THE MONEY."
"NOT FOR THE PERCENT."
THIS WAS A MONEY DEAL.
THERE WAS MONEY THERE.
BIG MONEY.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED TO GIVE
KIDS A SENSE OF INDEPENDENCE.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S TALIA GOLDFARB,
AND THIS IS MY FRIEND TEGAN.
HI.
Herjavec: HI.
I'M SEEKING $60,000
FOR 10% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY,
MYSELF BELTS, THE BELT
KIDS CAN FASTEN THEMSELVES.
AS YOU KNOW, A TODDLER'S
FAVORITE WORDS ARE...
"ALL MY MYSELF."
[ LAUGHTER ]
THESE WORDS
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE TRUE,
WHEN I WAS POTTY-TRAINING
MY 2-YEAR-OLD SON JAKE.
HE WAS DOING SO WELL
WITH HIS NEWFOUND INDEPENDENCE,
AND I COULDN'T HAVE BEEN
MORE PROUD.
BUT WITHOUT THE BULK OF A
DIAPER, HIS PANTS NO LONGER FIT.
HE WOULD RUN AND PLAY WITH
ONE HAND HOLDING UP HIS PANTS.
IT WAS RIDICULOUS, AND NOTHING
EXISTED TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
I NEEDED A BELT
THAT WAS EASY FOR JAKE TO USE,
WOULD KEEP HIS PANTS IN PLACE,
AND COULD BE QUICKLY UNDONE
AT A MOMENT'S NOTICE
WHEN HE WAS RACING
TO THE BATHROOM.
[ LAUGHS ]
DROOPY DRAWERS...
NO MORE.
OUR BELT SERVES THE ROLE
OF A REGULAR BELT,
COMPLEMENTS ANY OUTFIT,
BUT THE CLOSURE CAN BE DONE
WITH ONE HAND.
Both: TA-DA!
Herjavec: OH, COOL.
Greiner: AWW.
SINCE WE LAUNCHED,
WE'VE HAD GREAT SUCCESS,
BUT THERE ARE MANY AVENUES
FOR GROWTH,
SUCH AS LICENSING,
THE UNIFORM MARKET,
AND INTERNATIONAL EXPANSION.
WE KNOW THAT YOUR EXPERTISE
CAN HELP GET US THERE.
WHO WANTS TO CINCH UP A DEAL?
ME!
[ LAUGHTER ]
TEGAN, YOU WANT TO
PASS OUT THE BELTS?
TEGAN'S GONNA GIVE ALL OF YOU
A BELT TO LOOK AT.
TEGAN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Greiner: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOW OLD ARE YOU, TEGAN?
5.
5! WOW.
AWW.
I LIKE YOUR BELT.
IT'S GOT PIRATES ON IT.
DAYMOND,
WHY ARE THEY CALLED PIRATES?
'CAUSE THEY "ARR."
[are]
[ LAUGHTER ]
I THINK
THIS IS TOO SMALL FOR ME.
Goldfarb: OKAY, SO,
THE PARENT IN THE MORNING
SNAPS THE BELT
AROUND THE BELT LOOP,
AND IT BECOMES ATTACHED
TO THE PANTS.
THEN IT WEAVES THROUGH THE LOOPS
LIKE A REGULAR BELT,
AND THE CHILD CAN OPEN AND CLOSE
IT WITH ONE HAND AS YOU SAW.
SO IT KEEPS THEIR PANTS
IN PLACE,
ALWAYS CINCHES
TO THE RIGHT SPOT,
ALWAYS KEEPS THEIR PANTS UP,
AND THEY ALWAYS HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL,
"I DID IT MYSELF" MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT, TEGAN.
CAN YOU SAY BYE TO THE SHARKS?
BYE, SHARKS.
GIVE HER A DEAL.
John: ALL RIGHT, BYE!
[ LAUGHTER ]
Cuban:
GOOD JOB, TEGAN.
Herjavec:
BYE, TEGAN.
DON'T YOU NEED MULTIPLE SIZES?
BECAUSE THEY ONLY HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY
OF THE ONE INCH OF VELCRO
IN TERMS OF EXPANDABILITY.
WE DO, BUT WE'VE BEEN
IN BUSINESS FOR A LITTLE WHILE,
AND WE'VE PROVEN
THAT PEOPLE ARE EAGER
TO BUY THE NEXT SIZE UP
WHEN THEIR CHILD OUTGROWS.
MY CONCERN IS THAT IT FORCES YOU
TO CARRY MUCH MORE INVENTORY...
IT -- IT DOES.
...BECAUSE YOU NEED
SO MANY SIZES.
IT'S TRUE.
THIS IS TYPICAL KEVIN.
HE WANTS TO LOOK
FOR ALL THE NEGATIVE
IN THE PRODUCT RIGHT AWAY.
TELL US THE POSITIVE.
TELL US HOW LONG YOU'VE BEEN
IN BUSINESS. TELL US YOUR SALES.
SURE. SO, WE LAUNCHED
ALMOST 10 YEARS AGO.
IN SEPTEMBER,
IT'S OUR 10-YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
CONGRATS.
AS I SAID -- THANK YOU.
THE LAST YEAR,
OUR SALES WERE $205,000.
WHAT WERE THEY
THE YEAR BEFORE?
UM, $220,000.
OOH.
AND WHAT ABOUT
THE YEAR BEFORE?
THE LAST THREE YEARS,
WE'VE HAD A SLIGHT DECLINE
BECAUSE WE'RE SOLD ONLINE
AND ALSO MAINLY
INDEPENDENT BOUTIQUES.
AND WHEN THE RECESSION HIT,
WE FOUND A LOT OF OUR BOUTIQUES
WERE STRUGGLING.
THEY REALLY WERE BEING
MORE CONSERVATIVE.
EVEN A BIG CATALOG WE WERE IN
WENT BANKRUPT.
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE
WASTING MY MONEY
AND SPINNING MY WHEELS,
KNOCKING ON PEOPLE'S DOORS
WHO DID NOT WANT
TO TAKE ANYONE'S CALL.
AND SO WE DECIDED
TO KIND OF PUT A PAUSE
AND TO FOCUS ONLINE
AND TO WEATHER OUT THE STORM --
BUT YOU CAN'T BLAME
THE ECONOMY
FOR THREE YEARS
OF DECLINING SALES.
YOU CAN'T.
John: WHAT PRICE
DO YOU MAKE THEM AT?
CANVAS IS $2.20.
THE LEATHER'S $3.50.
OKAY. AND THEN YOU SELL THEM
FOR HOW MUCH?
WHOLESALE, $8.45,
AND $9.45 FOR THE LEATHER.
WHAT ABOUT
BIG-BOX RETAILERS?
WE WERE ON
A PRETTY HIGH TRAJECTORY,
AND THEN WE
KIND OF LEVELED OUT.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE BIG-BOX
STORES, THEY BECAME VERY NARROW.
BUT I FEEL LIKE NOW,
THE WHOLESALE STORES ARE BEING
MORE OPEN-MINDED AGAIN,
AND I FEEL LIKE
WE ARE ON A TRAJECTORY --
MY CONCERN IS,
OVER 10 YEARS,
TO TOP OUT AT $200,000
ON AN ITEM
AS BASIC AS A BELT --
THAT'S DECLINING.
IT REALLY IS --
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
IT'S DECLINING.
TO BE HONEST,
THE FIRST FIVE YEARS,
I WAS BALANCING MOTHERHOOD.
I HAD THREE LITTLE KIDS.
I'M GONNA GUESS
THE SIZE OF THE MARKET
IS AROUND $100 MILLION
A YEAR.
WHY DO WE HAVE
SO LITTLE OF IT?
WHAT IS HOLDING YOU BACK?
I THINK I'VE BEEN --
I'VE BEEN LEARNING,
AND I THINK I'VE LEARNED A TON
ABOUT MY MARKET.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE ECONOMIC
CLIMATE IMPACTED GROWTH,
BUT I'VE BEEN SPENDING THAT TIME
THINKING BIGGER.
I SHOULDN'T BE
POUNDING THE DOORS
OF INDEPENDENT,
SMALL BOUTIQUES.
I SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT LICENSING MY CLOSURE
TO LANDS' END, IZOD, THE GAP.
HAVE YOU REACHED OUT
TO THEM?
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
I'M HERE
IS TO HAVE
A STRATEGIC PARTNER.
I THINK SOMEONE LIKE YOU
CAN COME IN
AND REALLY HELP
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
WE HAVE
INTERNATIONAL PATENTS --
LOOK, YOU NEED
A STRATEGIC PARTNER.
BUT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR SOMEBODY
TO DO THE THINGS THAT,
IN REALITY...
NOT TO --
...YOU NEEDED TO FIGURE OUT
OVER FIVE YEARS.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
A ONE-YEAR START-UP HERE.
BUT I KNOW --
I KNOW THE PATH.
I JUST NEED A LITTLE HELP
OPENING THOSE DOORS.
O'Leary:
YOU HAVE ALL KINDS OF ISSUES.
THE MARKET'S TELLING ME
THIS IS NOT WORKING.
I'M SORRY.
$200,000 IN SALES
IS NOT A LOT IN A MARKET THAT'S
MUCH LARGER THAN THIS, OKAY?
IT IS.
IT IS MUCH LARGER.
AND, SO, THE MARKET
HAS SPOKEN TO ME,
AND IT'S SAID, "NOT WORTH
DOING A DEAL HERE." I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
DON'T THANK ME.
GO FIX IT.
NO, THANK YOU FOR YOUR FEEDBACK.
I WOULD LOVE TO FIX IT.
I KNOW I'M AT THE POINT
WHERE I NEED A PARTNER.
TALIA, YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN
AT THE POINT
WHERE YOU'VE NEEDED
A PARTNER, RIGHT?
MAYBE SO.
YOU'VE PRETTY MUCH HAD THE SAME
AMOUNT OF SALES EVERY YEAR.
SO MANY STORES HAVE CLOSED.
AND I FEEL LIKE MY STRATEGY
TO WAIT THAT OUT INSTEAD OF
CONTINUING TO BANG ON DOORS --
WAIT FOR WHAT?
WAIT FOR THAT --
WHAT FOR THAT --
WAIT -- WAIT FOR MORE BOUTIQUES
TO OPEN UP? WAIT -- WAIT --
WAIT FOR THAT WHOLESALE SIDE
TO BE OPEN TO TALKING TO PEOPLE,
WHICH THEY ARE NOW.
OKAY, SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
THE BUSINESS IS DECLINING,
AND YOU JUST WANT TO
WAIT FOR IT TO COME BACK?
NO, WE'RE -- WE --
WE'RE FOCUSING ONLINE.
IF A PRODUCT IS A GREAT PRODUCT,
WHETHER THE MARKET'S CRASHED,
ECONOMY'S BAD,
A GOOD PRODUCT SURVIVES
AND ACTUALLY
CONTINUES TO THRIVE.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I THINK HERE IS REALLY LACKING
IS YOUR DRIVE AND DETERMINATION
TO, NO MATTER WHAT IT TAKES,
EVERY MORNING,
YOU WAKE UP WITH,
"YOU KNOW WHAT? THIS ISN'T
WORKING, BUT I'M GONNA DO THIS.
"I DON'T CARE WHAT OBSTACLES
ARE IN MY WAY.
IT'S NOT WHO'S GOING TO LET ME,
IT'S WHO'S GOING TO STOP ME."
I DON'T SEE THAT IN YOU.
I'M OUT.
TALIA, LET ME TELL YOU
WHERE I'M AT.
THERE ARE TWO TYPES
OF WARRIORS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO SIT ON TOP OF THE HILL
AND BE STRATEGIC,
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THERE FIGHTING
HAND-TO-HAND COMBAT.
SOMETIMES,
YOU GOT TO DO BOTH.
SURE.
YOU'RE UP HERE.
I'M NOT --
WHEN I STARTED MY BUSINESS
10 YEARS AGO,
I THOUGHT WE WOULD DO $5 MILLION
IN SALES THE FIRST YEAR.
MY EGO'S THIS MASSIVE.
GUESS WHAT WE SOLD? $400,000.
SO GUESS WHAT I WAS DOING?
I WAS IN THERE
MAKING COLD CALLS,
GOING OUT THERE EVERY DAY.
YOU GOT TO HUSTLE.
WE'RE DOING A BIG 10-YEAR --
IT'S FOR OUR 10-YEAR LAUNCH.
NO, NO.
WE'RE DOING
A BIG MARKETING PUSH.
WE ARE ATTENDING TRADE SHOWS.
TALIA, STOP LOOKING
FOR THE POSITIVE. LOOK
FOR THE OBJECTIONS.
WELL, WHAT I'M TRYING
TO SHOW YOU IS THE OPPORTUNITY.
TALIA, YOU'RE NOT LISTENING.
NO, I AM.
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING.
I'M HOPING THAT YOU CAN SEE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
YOU KNOW WHAT? THE WORST LIES
YOU TELL IN LIFE ARE THE ONES
YOU TELL YOURSELF. AS
YOU'RE STANDING THERE,
YOU'RE SELLING YOURSELF.
I'M TRYING TO SELL YOU
ON OUR GREAT PRODUCT THAT --
TALIA, YOU'RE NOT
LISTENING TO HIM, RIGHT?
WE AGREE
YOU HAVE A GREAT PRODUCT.
BUT YOU --
WE'VE ALL SAID THAT, RIGHT?
RIGHT.
O'Leary: I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
MARKET. YOU DIDN'T SAY
IT WASN'T A GOOD PRODUCT.
THE MARKET SAYS
THIS PRODUCT'S $200,000 A YEAR.
POTTY-TRAINING'S
A $500-MILLION INDUSTRY.
YEAH, YEAH.
BUT NOT THIS ONE.
OKAY.
I-I DON'T NEED TO HEAR
MORE OPPORTUNITY.
I'M OUT.
I -- OKAY.
Cuban: I DON'T MEAN
TO BE RUDE, RIGHT?
I-I DON'T. I WANT YOU
TO BE SUCCESSFUL, RIGHT?
I SEE -- I SEE
THE FOUNDATION OF A BUSINESS.
AT LEAST
YOU'VE GOT A GOOD PRODUCT.
I DO.
BUT YOU'RE NOT A KILLER.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
DAYMOND, I-I THINK
YOU'D BE AN AMAZING PARTNER.
YOU'RE WHO I CAME HERE HOPING
WOULD BE INTRIGUED
BY WHAT WE'VE DONE SO FAR.
I KNOW YOU INVESTED
IN MISSION BELTS.
I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU
TO BECOME A BELT MOGUL.
AND I WOULD -- I WOULD LOVE
FOR YOU TO TAKE A CHANCE ON ME.
I KNOW OUR PRODUCT.
I KNOW WHAT IT NEEDS.
OKAY.
I KNOW WHAT PEOPLE LIKE
ABOUT IT.
[ SIGHS ]
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
TALIA HAS ONE LAST CHANCE
TO MAKE A DEAL
FOR HER CHILDREN'S BELT COMPANY,
MYSELF BELTS.
DAYMOND, I WOULD LOVE
FOR YOU TO TAKE A CHANCE ON ME.
I-I KNOW OUR PRODUCT.
I KNOW WHAT IT NEEDS.
OKAY.
I KNOW WHAT PEOPLE LIKE
ABOUT IT.
I GOT IT. I GOT IT.
I KNOW HOW TO MAKE IT GROW.
[ SIGHS ]
SO, THE LAST FIVE YEARS,
YOU CAME INTO, BASICALLY,
A RECESSION.
YOU PIVOTED. YOU MOVED AROUND.
YOU FIGURED A WAY
TO THEN GO ON TO HOW ONLINE
IS THRIVING RIGHT NOW,
AND YOU STAYED
AROUND THE SAME NUMBER.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THESE GUYS
ARE TALKING ABOUT, ALL RIGHT?
BUT THAT'S TYPICAL.
HE RARELY DOES.
John:
YEAH. WELL, THAT'S WHY --
THAT'S WHAT'S SO GREAT ABOUT US,
YOU KNOW?
I'M GONNA TAKE A RISK ON YOU.
OH, DAYMOND, THANK YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU $75,000
FOR 25%.
I'M SO GRATEFUL.
I'M SO EXCITED THAT YOU DON'T
HEAR WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
UM, COULD I COUNTER
AND SAY 20%?
[ Sighing ] OHH!
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, GOLLY!
WELL, OUR SALES ARE $200,000.
WE HAVE INTERNATIONAL PATENTS
Herjavec: TALIA, REALLY?
THE 5% IS GONNA --
OH, MY GOSH.
I-I -- I'M JUST --
I'M JUST ASKING.
O'Leary: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WANT TO STRING YOU UP
WITH ONE OF YOUR BELTS,
BUT THE VELCRO WON'T HOLD.
John: NO. NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I WANT
MY PARTNER TO DO --
NOT ACCEPT ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU DON'T GET
UNLESS YOU ASK.
NOW, OF COURSE, NO,
ON THE COUNTER, BUT...
[ LAUGHTER ]
...I DO LIKE THAT.
I BELIEVE IN YOU.
$75,000 FOR 25%.
THAT'S MY FINAL OFFER.
OKAY. I ACCEPT.
OH, COOL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOT TO GET A LITTLE EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
THEY JUST BEAT YOU UP.
I WASN'T EXPECTING THAT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
Cuban: CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GOOD JOB, DAYMOND.
YOU GUYS BEAT THAT GIRL UP
FOR NO REASON.
Goldfarb: I FEEL LIKE
I WAS JUST IN A FISTFIGHT.
IT WAS UNEXPECTED, 'CAUSE I'VE
WORKED SO HARD. I KNOW WHO I AM.
BUT WHEN DAYMOND CAME IN
AND SWOOPED IN, I FELT SO GOOD.